on top of being Ubisoft's
fastest-selling new IP the division
delighted British people for its
realistic look at queueing our national
pastime sadly for us Ubisoft have
decided to issue a fix for the body
collision issue that was causing players
to have to queue up behind each other to
interact with various objects I'm Lucy
and welcome to your orderly gamespot
news update the original issue arose and
players realized that they were
physically obstructed from moving
forward by other players at the start of
the game in the Brooklyn safe house this
caused players to have to form a queue
in order to interact with a laptop in
order to activate their agent Ubisoft
did tell players of a workaround whereby
they could force their way past others
by continuously running into them for
about three seconds but now the issue
has been fixed for the Brooklyn
safehouse the latest update patch notes
read fix for Brooklyn safe house
activation replacing the interaction
with a volume that activates the agent
when you step into it are you playing
and enjoying the division let me know in
the comments below I'll come find me on
Twitter I met Lucy James games stay
tuned for our review which will be
published once we feel we've spent
enough time with the game but for more
videos articles and gameplay from the
division make sure you head over to
gamespot com
you